after 10 long years final fantasy 15 is
out ready for intrepid explorers looking
for epic battles and valuable treasure
there's a lot to consider at any moment
in battle and if you want to be
efficient and successful in the open
world there are best practices that will
help you save time earn money and
quickly level up your party here are
some of the best tips and tricks to get
you started you then a long way to go
tion and that slack joldosh getting you
nowhere vanished before you jump in
consider hopping into the games option
menu beyond adjusting control and audio
preferences there are a few settings
related to your combat camera and
stamina meter that may seem small but
can have a big impact in the long run
noctus our hero can sprint until his
stamina meter runs out at which point he
will jog until his meter refills halfway
the best way to manage this process is
to make sure your stamina meter is
visible in the first place once that's
set there's also a trick to run
infinitely without running out of
stamina the trick is the moment before
your stamina meter runs out quickly let
go and repress the run button
this causes knocked us to - forward glow
green for an instant and then his
stamina bar will refill instantly
by default the in-game camera sticks
fairly close to the action during combat
this isn't usually a problem but to get
a better sense of your surroundings
during a chaotic fight it helps to have
a broader view of the battlefield head
into the camera settings menu and adjust
the distance to the far setting to get
this view as battles grow in scale over
time adjusting the camera ultimately
feels more like a requirement than an
option simply makes your life easier
when the going gets tough you can usher
knocked us to safety mid battle by
taking advantage of nearby war points a
tactic the game teaches you early on war
points will allow you to refill your MP
instantly and can be used to attack an
enemy from afar given the pace of combat
you may not think of halting your float
during battle but you should if not just
runs out of magic points he enters a
stasis State and moves sluggishly
incapable of tapping into his innate
powers noctus can also warp attack
enemies and the further the distance the
greater the damage multiplier that's
applied to his attack given that war
points are typically up high and on the
edge of an arena they are the perfect
place to warp attack enemies for maximum
damage
when you pull over at a roadside rest
stop or outpost look for the
fork-and-knife icon to locate a
restaurant or food merchants eating food
is one way to give yourself an advantage
in battle as the game's numerous dishes
boost your party's HP attack and defense
ratings including other stats as well
depending on what you eat be careful not
to rest at camp or a motel after eating
it will negate your buffs by the time
you wake up but don't just dine and dash
the people selling food are valuable
sources of information a quick chat with
service staff will pinpoint local shops
item procurement points and treasure
locations on your map do this at every
location the first time you visit and
you'll be thankful in the long run so
what do you want to know money can be
difficult to come by in yes in part
because unlike past Final Fantasy games
enemies no longer drop Gil in battle to
earn extra Gil and have enough on hand
to purchase restorative items before a
big fight make sure to speak to the same
cooks we mentioned earlier to sign up
for monster bounties these side quests
send you out into the field to kill a
particular group of monsters and there
are bounties for players of all levels
so you don't have to wait to get started
completing a bounty usually results in a
four figure payout and inexpensive or
hard to get restorative items
number loss for web after a hard day in
the field you may find yourself out and
about at nightfall but be careful once
the moon rises high level enemies can
rise from the earth at a moment's notice
putting your party in your progress in
serious danger you can only apply or
index P by sleeping after all there will
come a day when you are strong enough to
wander freely after dark but when you
see the Sun begin to set early on
consider heading to a nearby outpost or
campsite to catch your breath and wait
for sunrise the added benefit of calling
it a day and heading in for the night is
that you get to cash in your parties
experience points and hopefully level up
to get the most out of your hard earned
experience points consider staying in a
camper motel or a hotel rather than a
campsite while campsites give you a
chance to eat food and buff your stats
the Afra mentioned options come with
valuable XP multipliers at 30 guild per
night campers come with a 1.2 times
multiplier for 300 Gil roadside motels
offer a 1.5 times multiplier but in
golden quai and a few other towns you
can find hotels some which cost up to
10,000 Gil but the one in golden Quay
will double your experience points
motels sometimes at 300 or 500 Gil are
the best bet to make progress without
breaking your bank I was one hell of a
day huh yeah but it was fun every day's
fun even when we almost get ourselves
killed when you think that you've seen
everything in EOS think again there are
many hidden dungeons and secret items
strewn about the world but they aren't
always easy to find if you take a close
look at your world map and keep a keen
eye out for structures or anything that
looks curious tucked away in nature
examine it firsthand and you may be
surprised at what you find
you
every member of your party comes with
different strengths and weaknesses and
it's important to manage your equipment
accordingly to ensure that you're
getting the most out of your allies in
battle to give them a fighting chance
consider bolstering Prompto and noctis's
HP with bangle accessories Prompto has
low hitpoints anyway and noctis being
the leader of the pack can use all the
help he can get bigness is great at
magic but of course he can always be
better so focus on boosting his magic
stats and of course put spells in his
secondary weapons line and the same goes
for gladiolus even though he's strong
you want to make him stronger focus on
accessories that boost his attack rating
to get the most out of every one of his
hits the ascension grid is where you
spend valuable ability points earned
while leveling up and performing various
tasks around es there's one problem AP
belongs to your entire party not
individual characters to plan ahead and
avoid buyer's remorse study every panel
in the ascension grid and pinpoint the
short and long-term abilities that you
want the most to get you started
consider focusing on abilities that
boost noctis's warp attack and ones that
increase your chances of performing
linked strikes with teammates and it may
sound simple given the open world nature
of the game but take your time when
running between story missions and be
sure to sample the various types of side
quests that come your way
of course you boys can help me follow
Fantasy 15 story moves fast towards the
end and it's easy to get swept up in the
chain of events and lose sight of the
opportunities that surround you
diversifying your efforts across EOS
will not only give you multiple chances
to earn extra money and XP but it will
help you uncover the game's biggest
secrets
you
you